of course everybody's interested in the
Senate and Pietschmann trial at present
Donald Trump but it's an especially big
deal for one group of people
the production team over at c-span right
this is the big this is a huge thing for
c-span yesterday was a big day for them
and this is cool fortunately at the
start of the trial but we got some
cameras in there rolling in the c-span
control room to see what this big day
was like for them take a look okay guys
everybody in a huge day Senate and
Pietschmann trial of Donald Trump this
is our goddamn Super Bowl okay I need
everyone on their game all right hands
in everyone
hands in c-span on three one two three
c-span was hoping for a little more
energy got to be honest okay we're live
in three two one take two nice wide shot
Robbie you got around the tripod of
course I'm using the I'm good I love it
keep her right there okay now pending
you will do impartial justice this is uh
largely it until about one or two
o'clock in the morning you know what you
guys can all go home I think I got this
keep it right there Robbie very nice I'm
gonna kill myself
you